it's crazy because you know with what
you went through with your mom obviously
passing away i feel like
today there's a lot of kids who are
probably going through that
specific
ordeal um because of just the where
the world is with opiates and yeah and
fentanyl and like there's a lot of kids
who are dealing with their parents that
are addicted or dealing with losing
their parents to overdoses what would be
some advice you've lived it and
unfortunately obviously the absolute
worst thing came true for you but you
got through it you're here today what
would be some advice for someone
watching this who might be dealing with
someone who they love that's that's
going through something like that that
you could give them that maybe you know
you lived it for them kind of counseling
talk to somebody you know um
i wish i would have started sooner
i just actually started
mental health counseling
uh childhood trauma counseling
and i'm okay speaking about it because
um it's something that
yeah you know when you're a strong
person
and you're able to take the world on
your shoulders and and and perform under
pressure
oftentimes
you train yourself to to think that you
don't need
you know counseling you don't need to
talk about things that really bother you
like
it isn't until
something really triggers you that you
realize you ain't healed
and i've had those instances in my life
and i've ruined relationships because of
those types of things so
i was like you know what let me do this
for myself so that
you know i can have a family one day so
that i can be a father one day so that i
can be a better brother so i can be a
better friend like you know say it it
affects every part of your life as you
get older because
those things don't just leave
you know for me it was definitely a
driving force
it it taught me how to be numb it taught
me how to be
a perfectionist it taught me how to just
focus on work work work but it didn't
teach me how to heal so i had to take
that upon myself
um so i would say man
mental health
is a real thing
and it needs to be you know if you know
and you're dealing with something if
something's bothering you you get
triggered and and you see yourself being
affected by this specific space in your
life then you got to talk about it you
got to get hope for it yeah i think just
it's important for you to talk about
that because it lifts the stigma and i
think that the stigma started to get
lifted but like when you're somebody who
is the head of the household who so many
people depend on you're a leader in your
in your group your life it's like who do
you talk to right like who yeah who are
you gotta be somebody you trust you
gotta be somebody you trust a trusted
source and you gotta feel comfortable
but
definitely don't push it under the rug
you know you can't force someone to
stop using you can't force you know
someone to see how they're hurting you
sometimes they don't know
because they're it's a disease you know
addiction is a disease man and it's like
it's
it's something that that
attacks people physically and
spiritually
so it's a
it's a large karmic part of it that
comes with it's so much spiritually that
comes with it you know that if you're
if you you love somebody or you're close
to somebody that's experiencing that
it's important for you to also you know
get help for yourself while you're still
loving them through whatever they're
going through that's that's hey that's
right man yeah for sure